okay and now here are the nominees for
Best Adapted Screenplay The Ballad of
Buster Scruggs written by Joel Coen and
Ethan Coen
although Kenyon is based on a story by
Jack London the gal who got rattled is
inspired by a story by Stewart Edward
white/black Klansman written by jolly
Wachtel and David Rabinowitz and Kevin
Willmott and Spike Lee based on the book
by Ron stalwart can you ever forgive me
screenplay by Nicole olive Sena and Jeff
Whitty based on the book by Lee Israel
if bill Street could talk written for
the screen by very Jenkins based on the
book by James Palmer a star is born
screenplay by Erich walk and Bradley
Cooper and will finish
based on the 1954 screenplay by Moss
Hart in the 1976 screenplay by John
Gregory done and Joan Didion and Frank
Pearson based on a story by William
Wellman
and Robert Carson Charlie walk tale
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Charlie Wachtel David Rabinowitz in
Kevin Willmott
nomination for Spike Lee
all right Rob
all right do not turn that [ __ ]
clock on I want to thank Tonya Jackson
satchel the word today is irony the date
the 24th the month February the stores a
month of the air which old happens to be
Black History Month the year 2019 the
year 1619 history herstory
1619 2019 400 years 400 years our answer
was stolen from other Africa and brought
the Jamestown Virginia enslaved our ass
has worked it's the land from Kansas in
the morning they can't see at night my
grandmother's name is Sheldon Rita who
Libby honey is young who was a Spelman
College graduate even though her mother
was a slave my grandma who saved 50
years of Social Security checks for the
first grandchild
she called me spiky poo she put me
through Morehouse College and NYU grad
film NYU
before the world tonight I get praised
our ancestors called built this country
and was today along with the genocide of
his native people we all connect with
the ancestors we will have love wisdom
regaining when we gain our humanity will
be a powerful moment the 2020
presidential election is around the
corner let's all mobilize let's all be
on the right side of history
make the rope boy make the moral choice
between love versus hate let's do the
right thing
[Applause]